We've done two things up to this point. We
created a variable called year_joined, based on the tenure variable,
and we converted year_joined, to the variable year_joined_bucket. A categorical
variable. That bin their users into different groups. Let's table
this new variable to see the distribution in each group.
Here we can see that we have our four bins
of users, depending on when they joined Facebook, and it
looks like two people have a value of NA. Let's
use this new year joined bucket variable to create a
line graph Like we did for gender at the start of
the lesson. As a reminder, here's the code that generated this
plot earlier. Also, notice how we compute the median friend count
for each age using the fun.y parameter, and the summary for
the stat parameter. Using a similar code structure that we see
here. I want you to create a plot for friend count
versus age, so that each year join bucket has its own
line on the graph. In other words, each
bucket will be a color line that tracks the
median friend count across the age of users,
just as it did in this plot for genders.